have uh people on our streets jihadists
and their fellow Travelers calling for
the murder of Jewish people last week
when I was in London having driven by a
Hamas protest right by it and it was not
that comfortable to be quite honest uh I
asked it was I was actually on my way to
the ark Forum uh and I asked Douglas
Murray what do you do when
liberalism sort of gets to the end of
the road we uh people on our streets
jihadist and their fellow Travelers
calling for the murder of Jewish people
the destruction of the Jewish State and
the destruction of the British State
well I say in that situation we can
remain hand ringing liberals about this
and say as some let us say not be too
rude Centrist dads do in some of our
newspapers that we must simply ring our
hands at this and say this is one of the
prices we must pay to remain a liberal
society and I say screw that okay so
Douglas is making his thoughts on this
and his feelings on this very very clear
and the UK does have laws about
supporting a terrorist organization and
glorifying terrorism as he said earlier
so what do you do the question is if you
live in London right now if you live in
Paris if you live in Brussels or
Amsterdam where they have similar laws
to all of these things right they don't
exactly have the First Amendment
protections that we have here and by the
way there are things that we can do here
such as what Ronda santis has done in
Florida if you off for material support
say fund raise for these Hamas
organizations we're going to kick you
out of our campuses and things of that
nature but what are these liberal
societies going to do I suspect
unfortunately for my friend Douglas that
they are not going to do much I I don't
think that the people of Britain and the
people of France and and Holland and
Brussels uh Belgium will will do much of
anything I think they will complain
about it sort of uh but will they get
the police out there and will they
protect their minorities but it's not
even just protecting their minorities
will they protect the very ideals that
make Britain Britain and France France
Etc I'm not so sure that they will I'm
not so sure that we will do it here but
we better start thinking about it
because this ain't about the Jews when
they are done with the Jews as I keep
saying do you think they're going to
wash their hands of this whole thing or
will their lips and their mouths be
salivating right and going holy cow game
on let's do it